moppet ila is a huge fan of the royal
family she's been looking forward to the
Duke and Duchess of Cambridge's first
baby ever since the pregnancy was
announced last year
I think it's going to be the most
marvelous thing when we have Kate and
William's first baby I think the country
the world is going to go mad it's the
most important baby in the world
and it's not here yet the modest home in
a London suburb the self-styled heritage
house contains an enormous collection of
over 10,000 royal mementos a passion for
royal memorabilia began over 30 years
ago the collection ranges from cups and
plates to cardboard cutouts and
photographs the new baby souvenirs will
take pride of place right next to her
William and Kate dolls
the first souvenir will be a mug because
I love China and a plate I hope and you
know just general China obviously we
don't know yet whether a pink one or a
blue and if anybody was selling pink and
blue and I would buy one of each because
I know then I've got it right somewhere
porcelain manufacturer Hudson and
Middleton is working at full capacity to
cope with the demand for themes China
cups the gender a name of the baby have
to wait until a big day of course but
the market prototypes are already
finished in both blue and pink
but a royal baby we have got orders
currently of about six to eight thousand
and so really we are looking to do
something like fifty thousand pieces in
a very short window of about a month
Hudson and Middleton was founded in
stoke-on-trent in 1875 this is the heart
of the Potteries region of the English
Midlands named after the many ceramics
companies that were founded here in the
17th century although many have gone
factory chimneys still feature
prominently on Stoke skyline Hudson and
Middleton combines traditional
craftsmanship with modern technology
it's 40 strong workforce turns out 8,000
items of China a week and a variety of
designs the new commemorative mark
presents one potential headache for the
makers though the baby having an
inconveniently long name or names it
could test us it could be a situation
where we have to shrink the size of the
print or even consider a bigger beaker
if we get we end up with an enormous
amount of names but normally what would
happen is we can always put initials for
some of the names if we have to the
bookmakers in Britain famous for giving
odds on everything imaginable have seen
a flurry of bets on the baby's name
among the current favorites are
Alexandra Elizabeth Diana Victorian Bank
George
but it's not only the name that people
are betting on
anything from the hair color of the baby
to how much the baby's gonna weigh maybe
when it's born or even the day or time
that the baby's gonna be born and then a
couple funny ones like wherever it's
going to be maybe a cesarean or a
natural birth and the magazine that gets
the first official rights or the first
photos and the baby is not just an issue
of interest for those who fancy a
flutter I think it's very uplifting for
all the country
you know and it's something that's very
much needed you know I think it's
exciting and she seems like she'll be an
amazing mother the Royals are not really
something which I think about very often
so I guess not not really not much
excitement there Margaret
Tyler is very excited she already has
plans for the big day
I think I will have a little baby party
I don't drink myself only drink tea but
you know other people can drink
champagne and wet the baby's head and
it's such a joyous occasion I mean a new
baby's lovely in any family but this is
special because it's a future king or
queen I'm it's a very it for such a
small baby it's a lot isn't it for this
royal collector extraordinaire the
arrival of the future heir to the throne
can't come soon enough